[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportage en étant ensemble tous les
jours à 18h et 22h sur Public Sénat pour
donner du sens à l'actualité grâce à nos
experts et voici le sommaire de ce 3
avril la nuque et dépassé ce n'est pas
moi qui le dit mais Fabien Roussel le
secrétaire national du Parti communiste
la victoire dans une législative
partielle d'une dissident PS face à la
candidate officielle hier en Ariège
monastère d'implosion l'Union des
gauches ce sera l'un des thèmes de notre
débat d'actu politique dans un instant
et puis tout à l'heure dans 45 minutes
c'est la crise du logement que je vous
propose d'analyser
100000 personnes mallogées à Marseille
donc c'est à marseillais sur 8 donc si
vous prenez à Marseille une personne que
vous croisez sur 8 elle vit dans un
taudis ou assimilé et ensuite on a 14000
personnes qui vivent à la rue
le mal logement qui s'aggrave comme le
dénonce la Fondation Abbé Pierre ici à
Marseille mais aussi le marché de
l'immobilier qui se contracte la
construction de logements neuf qui
tourner au ralenti que propose le
gouvernement pour sortir de cette
spirale négative les mesures
indispensables de transition écologique
du secteur peuvent-elles aggraver la
situation ne ratez pas notre débat de
société tout à l'heure mais d'abord sur
le front de la réforme des retraites les
regards se tournent vers Matignon cette
semaine la première ministre a lancé ce
matin une série de consultations
politiques au syndicale Jonathan du
priez
c'est une semaine de tous les dangers
qui s'ouvrent pour Elisabeth borne pour
sortir de l'impasse sur les retraites et
bâtir la suite du quinquennat la
locataire de Matignon reçoit toute la
semaine élu et partenaires sociaux des
sénateurs ont ouvert le bal des ce matin
Hervé Marseille patron des centrist au
Sénat a appelé la première ministre à
faire un pas vers certaines
organisations syndicales pour ne pas
bloquer de futurs réformes nous avons
dit à la première ministre que ce
n'était pas une bonne chose pour le pays
que d'avoir un blocage de cette nature
notamment avec les syndicats ce que la
vie ne s'arrêtait pas au dossier des
retraites derrière il va y avoir une loi
travail il va y avoir d'autres dossiers
qui nécessiteront une concertation forte
avec les syndicats et tout
particulièrement la CFDT et il est
indispensable de briser la glace si je
puis dire avec ces organisations là mais
ces consultations pourraient tourner au
dialogue de sourds dès demain hormis
certains élus RN où LR la nuque a décidé
de boycotter l'invitation de la première
ministre invitation qu'il voit comme une
manœuvre politique pour amadouer
l'opposition l'objectif de ces
entretiens ça a été dit d'ailleurs par
Monsieur Macron quand il a confié à
Madame borne c'est d'essayer de trouver
une nouvelle majorité d'élargir la
majorité pour la suite du quinquennat en
essayant de faire comme si la bataille
sur les retraites était close mais elle
est pas close l'opposition elle est
toujours aussi forte tous les regards
seront tournés vers mercredi journée à
haut risque pour Elisabeth borne qui
reçoit les syndicats Matignon la tâche
de la première ministre s'annonce
délicate l'Inter syndical menace de
claquer la porte si le gouvernement
refuse d'aborder la question du report
de l'âge légal à 64 ans qu'est-ce que
vous attendez de cette rencontre avec la
première ministre bah le retrait de la
réforme des retraites c'est simple donc
ça peut être très court de toutes les
organisations syndicales sont
déterminées à dire que on ne peut pas
parler d'autre sujet tant qu'on ne
retire pas cette réforme en fait c'est
ce que le gouvernement doit comprendre
c'est que aujourd'hui ça n'est pas
possible de diriger le pays si on ne
retire pas cette réforme pour syndicat
et opposition l'exécutif consulte pour
gagner du temps avant la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel sur le texte
retraite le 14 avril en dépit des
désaccords Elisabeth borne a affirmé
aujourd'hui être à l'écoute de tous les
sujets
les consultations à Matignon l'avenir de
la nuque mais aussi Gérald Darmanin qui
dénonce dans une interview au Journal du
Dimanche le 6 le terrorisme intellectuel
de l'extrême gauche voilà les trois
thèmes majeurs que l'on va aborder dans
ce débat avec Sophie dravinel bonsoir
déjà en train de prendre des notes
bienvenue Bienvenue à vous grand
reporter au service politique du Figaro
j'accueil Bastien François bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi vous êtes
professeur de sciences politiques à
l'Université Paris implanté on Sorbonne
Anne busina bonsoir bienvenue à Charlène
vous êtes constitutionnaliste et
Matthieu croissanto éditoris politique
bonsoir Mathieu bienvenue à vous aussi
Sophie ravinels moi je on parlait là
pendant juste avant que l'émission
démarre c'est quoi c'est plutôt une
période d'attente qui commence on va
dire jusqu'au 14 avril jusqu'à la
décision du du Conseil constitutionnel
je vois mal ce qui peut ressortir des
consultations cette semaine à Matignon
et vous d'autant que moi non plus je
dois dire parce que d'autant que ce que
je notais là justement c'était cette
espèce de de oui et non des parties
d'opposition de la nubes en particulier
de dire bah en fait non on refuse de
voir Elizabeth borne mais quand même là
on vient de recevoir un communiqué des
écologistes qui disent mais en fait on
veut pas le rendez-vous mais quand même
on ira la voir on a demandé un
rendez-vous en urgence pas sur l'agenda
parlementaire mais sur les tensions dans
la société donc en fait tout le monde
est un peu dans une position de dire il
faut attendre il faut trouver le temps
d'attendre mais personne ne va être
absent de la séquence et les parties
politiques pas plus que les autres pas
plus que les syndicats évidemment bah si
à François qu'est-ce que vous pensez du
timing de la chronologie de cette
semaine de rencontre il y a deux
semaines en fait il y a la première
semaine celle dans laquelle nous sommes
où nous savons déjà que il y aura une
journée de nationale de mobilisation
jeudi et nous savons déjà que le
mercredi à la rencontre la rencontre
syndicale Premier ministre là après le
premier ministre si j'ai bien compris
aurait préféré que la rencontre soit en
début de semaine et syndicats ont
préféré que ce soit le mercredi pour des
raisons évidentes c'est à dire que si il
sortait de Matignon sur un désaccord
très fortement marqué et on peut
imaginer voit bien que ça sera le cas
évidemment ça booste ça booste quand
même un peu les les manifestants
derrière bon donc c'est une semaine
d'attente mais avec quand même un point
d'atterrissage jeudi qui sera quand même
scruté de très près parce que le niveau
de la mobilisation même s'il faut pas
faut pas mettre tout dans le niveau de
la mobilisation
la dernière fois on a dit que il y avait
une même certains parler de d'une forme
de démobilisation c'est pas du tout vrai
les niveaux de mobilisation sont quand
même très élevés sur la durée bon si
vous prenez par exemple les gilets
jaunes avec tout leur samedi de suite
c'était infiniment moins de monde donc
là c'est vraiment une tenir si longtemps
donc il y a une mobilisation très forte
mais c'est vrai que je dis prochain ça
sera lu sans doute une façon un peu
différente et peut-être plus
enfin ça dira en réalité s'il y a eu
s'il y a eu un début d'affaiblissement
ou si on est quand même dans une
continuité une continuité qui au-delà de
la décision du Conseil constitutionnel
parce qu'il y a aussi ce nouveau
rendez-vous alors là à mon avis il va y
avoir là le temps va être vraiment très
suspendu il y a d'ailleurs ce sera un
vendredi exceptionnellement on sera à
l'antenne le vendredi 14 avril pour vous
proposer une édition spéciale sur cette
décision du conseil cautionnel
anne-charles busina vous avez pas fini
de répondre à la question dans les deux
semaines qui viennent justement sur ce
qu'on peut atteindre du Conseil consuel
peut-être je vais vous la poser
différemment à quel point il est
sensible aux arguments de la rue et à
l'actualité un conseil constitutionnel
il est censé juger en droit uniquement
en droit c'est le grand paradoxe c'est
qu'en fait on peut attendre de lui qu'il
ne le soit pas du tout puisque
techniquement c'est quand même notre au
juge constitutionnel alors on n'a jamais
voulu l'appeler cours constitutionnel
mais
sa mission c'est l'indépendance et c'est
l'indépendance organique mais aussi
l'indépendance politique bien évidemment
alors avec un conseil conditionnel qui a
pas une tâche facile parce que déjà il a
une composition très politisée et puis
en plus on est l'un des
le système le seul système à avoir un
contrôle a priori des lois ordinaires
c'est-à-dire juste après le vote de la
loi qui est sur des charbons ardents on
vient de voter on vient de s'échapper
les saisines elles-mêmes reviennent
complètement sur des arguments bien plus
politiques que juridique et donc on voit
bien que le Conseil constitutionnel
qu'il décide de faire passer la
conformité à la Constitution sera
considérée comme un chien du pouvoir et
qu'à la rigueur il décide au contraire
de censurer sera considérer comme le
chien de garde du côté de l'opposition
donc c'est vrai que la mission du
Conseil conditionnel est très délicate
dans ces moments-là alors on peut
espérer qu'il en est l'habitude depuis
58 c'est vrai que il y a eu les lois de
nationalisation de privatisation dans
des délais très restreints avec une même
composition donc la difficulté de se
dédire tout en gardant les impératifs
constitutionnels on a eu les décisions
déconfinement et de confinement de la
part du Conseil constitutionnel où on
était suspendus alors le gouvernement
elle a fâcheuse tendance de déclarer la
conformité à la Constitution avant le
Conseil lui-même en déjà donnant
l'application des règlements
d'applications mais sans cela on peut
dire que c'est une habitude pour le
conseil de se prononcer très à chaud
même si c'est vrai qu'ici on a le
sentiment qu'il y a il y a presque une
tension politique autour de cette
décision dans la rue et on peut estimer
que évidemment au sortir de cette
décision il y aura aussi une
contestation et on peut imaginer qu'il y
aura une autre journée d'action
exactement la veille ou peut-être le
jour même de la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel on suivra ça ça dépendra
de la décision qui sera sans doute prise
par l'intersyndical au soir de la
prochaine mobilisation c'est à dire
jeudi soir donc consultation peut-être
pas pour grand-chose pourtant la
première ministre fait comme si écoutait
Elisabeth borne ce matin ce midi
on a beaucoup de sujets à aborder
ensemble et y compris des sujets qui ont
été mis en lumière à l'occasion de la
réforme des retraites sur la qualité de
vie au travail sur les fins de carrière
sur la prévention de la pénibilité moi
je serai à l'écoute de tous les sujets
que les organisations syndicales
voudront aborder et j'espère qu'on
pourra bien prendre le temps de parler
de tous ces sujets Sophie davinel elle
doit alors la feuille de route de du
prénom impulse et d'élargir sa majorité
est-ce que ce serait pas plutôt de la
fortifier c'est-à-dire faut quand même
s'occuper de modem d'horizons le
l'épisode 49.3 laisser des traces oui
l'épisode 49-3 elle essaie des traces on
le voit bien dans les critiques plus ou
moins audibles de certains
parlementaires députés du MoDem qui ont
dit faudrait peut-être mettre sur pause
la réponse d'Elizabeth borne de dire
mais je peux pas faire de surprise on
peut pas mettre sur pause alors qu'en
fait d'une certaine façon et sans
revenir sur notre discussion précédente
du Conseil constitutionnel il y a quand
même des façons de faire un peu attendre
c'est-à-dire que le gouvernement aura le
choix si jamais il y avait dans la vie
positif alors vous me reprenez si je
n'ai pas les termes exacts parce que
c'est toujours très précis mais voilà on
est très scrupuleux avec ça absolument
et du coup nous on a un vocabulaire plus
plus plus plus général mais donc si un
avis positif est donné pour le rythme
référendum d'initiative partagée une
fois que bon la loi sera le même jour il
faut le rappeler le Conseil donnera sa
décision à la fois sur la la pardon hein
par exemple des retraites et sur le
référendum absolument et du coup comme
ce sera le même jour bon il y a pas de
question a priori de temporalité donc la
loi sera promulguée et ensuite il y aura
la question de savoir ce qui sera décidé
pour le gouvernement parce qu'il y a
encore d'autres étapes pour que la loi
soit appliquée il ne suffit pas qu'elle
soit promulguée et du coup là il y aura
la possibilité pour le gouvernement
d'attendre un petit peu de voir si le
riz peut prendre en l'opinion publique
ou non si les signatures les soutiens
qui sont ces votes que les Français vont
pouvoir si jamais voilà déposer enfin
ils vont tout le monde va pouvoir
pouvoir voter si on s'amment assez vite
à un million de millions 3 millions on
pense là que effectivement la question
va être là de sur la 9 mois pour
atteindre les 4 millions 8 fois
ils ont 9 mois donc on va voir un petit
peu donc là ça laisse quand même un tout
petit peu de marge après c'est vrai
qu'Elizabeth borne elle est dans une
situation extrêmement compliquée parce
qu'elle sait de ce que nous nous savons
qu'au sein de son gouvernement sa
présence même est un peu en question et
c'est cette dureté là de la vie interne
à toute la majorité on sait aussi
puisque sur public c'est là on peut le
dire il y a des élections sénatoriales
qui vont avoir lieu en septembre et que
même dans cette perspective là au sein
de la majorité je pense à Edouard
Philippe certains veulent prendre plus
de place au Sénat aussi et que
énormément de questions se posent sur la
composition d'un futur gouvernement
enfin tout est ouvert
tous les dangers pour Elisabeth borne
puisqu'en gros on va savoir elle est en
sursis aujourd'hui étant sur si
actuellement et on va savoir au-delà de
la Quinzaine pas d'ailleurs de cette
semaine mais plutôt de la quinzaine de
quoi son avenir peut être constitué ce
dont on va ça va percevoir dans les
jours qui viennent c'est est-ce qu'elle
est encore légitime et crédible non pas
institutionnellement parce qu'elle est
en poste elle est mais dans les yeux de
ses interlocuteurs ça c'est il y a
quelque chose de terrible quand vous
êtes mort politiquement c'est que vous
avez parfois du mal à l'admettre vous
pouvez être encore en poste mais quand
les gens vous voient ils vous voient ils
regardent à travers il y a plus personne
et donc ils viennent vous voir poliment
parce que il respecte la fonction il
respecte les usages républicains mais
est-ce que les syndicats vont se dire de
toute façon elle est finie ça sert à
rien discuter avec elle on claque la
porte est-ce que les républicains
qu'elle peut être tenter de séduire
est-ce que sa majorité qu'elle peut
tenter de conforter vas-y de toute façon
ça ne se jouera pas avec elle d'une
certaine manière ça ne dépend plus
d'elle à moins qu'elle sorte un
incroyable truc de son tiroir mais je ne
vois pas quoi parce qu'en terme de
gestes politiques aujourd'hui et les
relativement prisonnière Bastien
François entre deux hypothèses une
Elisabeth borne en place pour encore
plusieurs
mois ou un nouveau Premier ministre vous
choisissez laquelle
je vais vous le dire dans un autre ordre
je pense d'abord qu'il faut un nouveau
gouvernement enfin je veux dire ça va
s'imposer ce gouvernement
personne connaît les ministres il est
pléthorique sa communication est quand
même il imprime le moins
mais je crois que ça déjà et le
président de la République et il lisait
bedborne on avait conscience oui et ça
peut être avec Élisabeth borne à sa tête
alors c'est ça parce que le problème ça
va être de trouver un premier ministre
et c'est toujours un problème de trouver
un premier ministre c'est d'un choix
politique extrêmement bon et là il a pas
qui aujourd'hui dans dans la majorité
peu incarner le en même temps
[Musique]
c'est vraiment remanier concrètement et
le par exemple le différentiel entre le
gouvernement borne 1 et le gouvernement
borne II quand on a eu des élections
législatives a été quand même de l'ordre
du hiatus minuscule j'ai peur qu'on soit
un petit peu dans ce type de romaniement
là c'est à dire qu'on a l'impression que
personne ne veut y aller l'élargissement
de la majorité les LR essaie d'y jouer
un rôle particulier mais on oublie quand
même pas le camouflé qu'ils ont apposé à
la majorité parce que il faut pas il
faut être honnête ce 49-3 il a été
dégainé parce qu'on était pas sûr des
votes des LR même donc il y a quand même
aussi peut-être différent avec un Gérard
Larcher à Matignon
c'est qu'on a un sénat républicain très
ancré dans une famille les républicains
qui est un peu traditionnel un peu celle
qu'on avait l'habitude d'avoir même sous
Nicolas Sarkozy etc et on peut estimer
qu'elle sera peut-être le futur alliée
de la loi immigration en tout cas de la
demi-loie immigration qui sera donc
favorable au LR mais la grande question
c'est est-ce qu'on peut encore incarner
un gouvernement de recomposition avec
avec un premier ministre de droite alors
que finalement le problème du message
qui a été celui de la réforme des
retraites est un message social mais
est-ce que le président qui n'a pas joué
de message social sur la réforme des
retraites le jour est sur un
élargissement gouvernemental il y a
quand même quelque chose dans l'ordre de
se remaniement qui risque soit d'être
cosmétique soit s'il est de l'ampleur
attendu d'être très contradictoire avec
le message qui vient d'être celui de la
séquence qui se fait juste l'hypothèse
c'est aussi parce qu'il a été ministre
qui avait qui a refait les lois sur la
voilà sur la représentativité syndicale
notamment il avait plutôt un bon
dialogue avec les syndicats historiques
voilà ça majorité mais mais on est quand
même tous frappés par l'absence de banc
comme on est au football de la macronie
ça fait cinq ans en 5 ans un parti
politique c'est quand même chargé de
faire émerger des idées c'est aussi
chargé de faire émerger des cadres et
sosie chargé de faire émerger des élus
les idées elles sont dans la tête du
président les cadres on les cherche
toujours les élus ils ont pas réussi à
s'implanter aux élections intermédiaires
donc ça pose quand même euh une vraie
une vraie question sur le fonctionnement
du parti présidentiel et la majorité
aussi de ce parti qu'à la rigueur la
candidature de Gérard Larcher aurait
peut-être tendance à remodeler un petit
peu puisque lui est plutôt un élu du
territoire en tout cas c'est vraiment
comme ça qu'il se présente et ça
viendrait d'une certaine façon parce que
évidemment on en débat entre nous on ne
sait absolument pas où en sont enfin en
tout cas moi le niveau de de
d'exploration de cette hypothèse de nos
confrères et qui a été largement à
plusieurs reprises déjà évoquées mais
c'est vrai que pourquoi pas imaginer
cela si jamais le président parce qu'il
faut se souvenir qu'il a quand même
encore quatre ans devant lui il va
falloir continuer un peu et avoir Gérard
lâcher avec lui c'est peut-être revenir
pourquoi pas sur cette réforme des
institutions qu'il portait et qui
peut-être pourrait permettre d'emporter
quelque chose dans l'opinion des
Français même si on pense que les
Français sont pas forcément passionnés
par les institutions il y a quelque
chose qui pour Emmanuel Macron en tout
cas qui veut laisser sa trace il a voulu
la laisser sur les retraites c'est loupé
sur la question de l'immigration c'est
mal en manger sur le travail les lois
travaillent à venir on ne sait pas ce
que ça va donner sur les institutions ça
pourrait être une solution pour vraiment
essayer de poser sa marque ça
reviendrait aussi
sans doute peut-être préparer parce que
je parlais des élections du Sénat qui
vont quand même être importantes il faut
pas l'oublier mais sur les Européens à
venir aussi et là peut-être qu'Emmanuel
Macron va chercher là aussi encore parce
qu'il y a évidemment trois grandes
forces aujourd'hui en France trois
grandes forces politiques tout le monde
a les yeux tournés vers 2027 mais il y a
à gauche des oppositions nette sur le
rapport des Français à l'Europe et donc
est-ce que Emmanuel Macron ne voudrait
pas essayer de profiter de cette
situation d'une UPS divisée du du RN un
peu opposé sur la question européenne
pour lui s'imposer dans une union avec
la droite qui serait clarifiée et qui
viendrait voilà c'est pourquoi pas après
tout est envisageable effectivement vous
voulez encore dire un mot peut-être
juste sur le point de la réforme des
institutions c'est vrai que elle a
bloqué par rapport à Gérard Larcher
justement
il y aurait des belles négociations
constitutionnelles
je reste sur les enjeux de cette semaine
de cette quinzaine même autour de la
réforme des retraites avec dans
l'équation
une nouvelle variable on va dire c'est
ce féminer la secrétaire général de la
CGT qui vient de remplacer Philippe
Martinez elle était sur France Inter ce
matin en l'écoute moi je vais être
sincère avec vous je crois pas à la
pause en fait quand on suspend ses qu'on
retire c'est ce qui s'est passé avec le
CPE et il y a pas d'autres sorties de
crise que le retrait de cette réforme
moi je suis convaincu que cette réforme
de toute manière de s'appliquera jamais
il y a un vice de forme d'origine et
d'une façon d'une autre elle ne
s'appliquera pas c'est pour ça qu'il
faut être très nombreux et nombreuses
dans la rue le 6 avril prochain parce
que cette mobilisation qui permettra
qu'elle ne s'applique pas bah c'est
François est-ce que ça qu'est-ce que ça
change est-ce que ça change quelque
chose d'ailleurs dans le rapport de
force ou dans l'équation dont je parlais
pour la première ministre je suis pas
sûr alors ce qui est certain c'est
qu'elle a été élue dans des conditions
où elle est un point d'équilibre entre
les plus radicaux et disons ceux qui
sont plus ouverts non pas un dialogue
avec le gouvernement mais à construire
une interdit syndicale en respectant les
points de vue des uns et des autres bon
donc elle elle doit tenir cet équilibre
bon mais elle arrive à un moment où
justement elle parlait de la pose la
fenêtre d'opportunité de la pause elle a
été refermée en fait
Laurent Berger a proposé le terme de
pose il s'est fait renvoyer dans ses
cordes il a après alors c'était c'était
un peu bizarre comme comme proposition
mais il a évoqué la possibilité qu'il y
ait des médiateurs voilà de nouveau
renvoyer dans ce corps là maintenant
tout le monde est sur une position
beaucoup peut-être plus raide encore que
au début et elle finalement elle exprime
cette position c'est ce qu'elle a dit
très clairement ce matin donc je suis
pas sûr que ça changera grand chose je
pense que les choses vont être très
clarifiées ça va être plus facile pour
l'avenir là il y avait des discussions
entre les organisations syndicales avec
un dirigeant celui de la CGT qui était
quand même un petit peu contesté on
savait pas du tout ce qui arriverait
derrière là les choses sont assez
claires même si ce matin elle était très
prudente je sais pas si vous avez
remarqué elle disait tout le temps que
c'était pas elle qui décidait
systématiquement c'était un collectif
bon je pense que dans quelques mois elle
aura pris l'assurance bah non son nom
mais là elle était vraiment extrêmement
prudente dans ce que vous décriviez au
début de votre interventions
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a cette équilibre
à maintenir c'est peut-être sa première
priorité et sa première mission alors
qu'elle vient d'être désigné la marge de
manœuvre de l'exécutif finalement la
leçon qu'on peut tirer nos premiers
échanges c'est qu'elle se rétrécit
peut-être encore plus à l'occasion de
son allocution devant la Convention
nationale de la fin de vie le président
de la République a peut-être esquissé
une piste regardez je souhaite à ce
titre que cet instrument désormais mûr
de la convention citoyenne soit mise en
oeuvre pour d'autres sujets c'est
pourquoi je compte dans les prochaines
semaines saisir le Conseil économique
social et environnemental sur d'autres
questions relatives à la vie de la
nation
est-ce que là le président de la
République esquisse une sorte de alors
je sais pas si c'est le plan B c'est oud
mais enfin en tout cas pour pour
contourner la majorité introuvable de
l'Assemblée le fait d'utiliser de
multiplier les conventions citoyennes ou
formules de ce type alors on avait déjà
ça un petit peu depuis le mois de
juillet avec le Conseil national de la
refondation qui ressemblait très
fortement à une assemblée hors de
l'Assemblée c'est toujours un peu le
problème de ce qu'on appelle la
démocratie participative c'est-à-dire
que faire participer le peuple c'est une
grande vocation c'est le sens même de la
démocratie qui en France est semi-direct
c'est à dire à la fois représentative et
par l'usage normalement du référendum
mais quand vous faites participer le
peuple encore faut-il que le résultat
qui est repris par le gouvernement soit
à la hauteur et c'est vrai qu'au fond on
a le sentiment que quand on multiplie
ces conventions citoyennes il faut pas
non plus ça devienne du pur bavardage et
qu'on donne le sentiment qu'on donne du
pouvoir au peuple ont finalement le lui
retirant au stade des résultats donc
essayez de adorer son image avec cette
idée de consulter ça fait évidemment
partie on espère de la nouvelle nouvelle
méthode puisqu'il serait temps qu'on en
est une et cette nouvelle méthode peut
être que c'est celle de la consultation
plus ouverte avec notre première
ministre qui consulte les syndicats avec
le président qui ouvre des sujets au
Conseil économique social et
environnemental mais encore une fois
faut-il que ces éléments se retrouvent
dans la décision parce que ce qui est
assez frappant notamment avec la
discussion autour du projet de loi de
réforme des retraites pour les
l'intersydicales c'est que la première
ministre nous dit qu'en fait on va
discuter de tout sauf de ça et que les
syndicats ne viennent discuter que de
cela donc on a même pas les bases d'un
dialogue sur un même sujet donc c'est ça
qu'il faut il faut avoir en tête c'est
que consulter c'est une bonne chose mais
toujours avec une idée que le résultat
soit à la hauteur de la consultation
Satan les uns les autres que ça ne dure
pas très longtemps éventuellement
mercredi mais on fait on verra bien on
va pas préjugés sur le fond peut-être
Sophie dravinel qu'est-ce que vous
pensez du discours d'Emmanuel Macron sur
sur la fin de vie sur ces sur ces enjeux
évidemment majeurs
ne soit pas l'otage dans une situation
politique qui ne lui est pas favorable
je pense que la France et les Français
méritent mieux que cela ce débat qui est
extrêmement important qui est celui du
rapport que les Français entretiennent
avec la mort qui a été extrêmement
bousculée pendant toute la crise du
covid on a vu à quel point on a les
Français ont été privés de la mort
justement du fait de l'État et de la
façon avec laquelle il a décidé sans
doute par bonne par bonne conscience
sans doute par volonté de protéger les
Français mais les privés de leur deuil
donc ça c'est un premier point ensuite
la question des soins palliatifs et la
question de de l'engagement que l'on met
dans ses soins palliatifs et donc de
l'engagement financier de l'État
là-dedans et ça je pense que il y aurait
beaucoup à dire sur la facilité
peut-être que l'on pourrait avoir de se
dégager de cet engagement envers les
soins palliatifs avec une loi euthanasie
et quand on regarde ce qui s'est passé
au Canada avec des années et des années
de recul et je pense qu'il y aurait
aussi beaucoup de prévention alors à
avoir sur la question des libertés
individuelles et dans une société dans
laquelle les questions économiques et la
question de l'économie en matière de
santé risque enfin voilà vous voyez tous
les sujets que j'aborde et sur je
regrette évidemment majeur mais est-ce
qu'ils n'ont pas été abordés justement
dans cette convention citoyenne moi je
trouve que celui qui a présidé cette
convention citoyenne était lui-même à
donner déjà dès le départ son opinion
est un peu la direction dans laquelle de
fait c'est aller et c'est ça qui est un
peu regrettable c'est-à-dire alors oui
la convention fait quand même beaucoup
sur les soins palliatifs c'est une très
grosse demande qui est consensuelle pour
le coup partagé par tous les citoyens
aussi
qu'on ne voudrait pas
Vienne retirer
cette envie que les Français ont est-ce
que je voulais enfin en matière de soins
palliatifs et donc d'accompagnement du
mieux possible jusqu'à la fin et moi
j'entendais encore juste pour un point
là-dessus Sandrine Rousseau dire parce
qu'elle est particulièrement donc cette
députée écologiste particulièrement
touché pour avoir vu sa mère accompagnée
et sa mère partir et donc évidemment les
personnes qui ont vécu cela en parle
différemment en disant mais de dire
voilà les médecins
enfin c'était la façon dont elle en
parlait n'était pas du tout juste par
rapport à ce que les médecins vivent au
quotidien et on sent bien que les
Français ont encore besoin d'avancer
là-dessus alors je voulais vous entendre
sur ce thème parce que je sais que voilà
c'est vous aviez une réflexion qui était
intéressante mais ça me nourrit encore
plus sur finalement l'usage et là on
revient à ce que ce que une convention
citoyenne peut faire dans un dans un
équilibre démocratique c'est intéressant
parce que il y a eu un travail il y a eu
un travail de longue durée d'un collège
de citoyen tirés au sort etc et il y a
toujours on se pose toujours des
questions sur la façon dont ça s'est
passé sur les sur ce qu'on va en faire
laissez la parole sur la on avait vu
aussi ce que je voulais dire auparavant
c'est que à la suite des gilets jaunes
il y avait eu exactement la même
dynamique et il y avait eu cette
convention sur entre guillemets sur le
climat et on avait vu à quel point il
n'avait pas
je vais appliquer je vais appliquer et
puis finalement on s'enfiltre et
finalement ça n'a pas été tout à fait le
cas bah si François oui c'est à dire que
bon c'est un outil formidable en réalité
quand il est bien utilisé c'est vraiment
un outil formidable on voit que comment
des citoyens s'emparent d'un certain
nombre de questions les discutent on
retrouve vraiment la délibération au
sens presque de la théorie politique qui
n'existe plus du tout dans les
départements dans les dans les Parlement
dans le monde donc c'est un outil
formidable
mais effectivement la question c'est
comment ça s'articulait la décision
alors il y avait eu une maladresse mais
qui a eu beaucoup d'effets d'Emmanuel
Macron au moment de la convention
citoyenne sur le climat quand il a dit
sans filtre sans filtre ça n'existe pas
enfin il faut dire la vérité ça n'existe
pas bon donc là en fait l'enjeu ça va
être est-ce que la loi
qui sera après qui pourra évidemment
après être amendé discuté etc
normalement est-ce que la loi qui sera
issue des recommandations de cette de
cette convention citoyenne est-ce
qu'elle va respecter ce qu'elle dit la
convention citoyenne c'est ça l'enjeu et
c'est très important c'est là que doit
pas y avoir de filtre après il y a du
filtre après ça y compris
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que moi
je trouve franchement c'est un outil
extrêmement intéressant pour commencer à
mettre en discussion un certain nombre
de questions très compliquées
c'est-à-dire au moins retenir un
ensemble de thèmes sur lesquels il faut
répondre et ça c'est quand même pas mal
allez encore deux grands thèmes dont on
n'a pas parlé dans ce débat et il nous
reste un quart d'heure donc on va on va
on va avancer grâce à vous Mathieu avec
donc les déclarations du ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin au Journal
du Dimanche je vous dis il va revenir
oui car il faut lui reconnaître une
certaine audace un certain culot même un
qui font la marque des j'ai des grands
faux en politique sur le papier le
ministre de l'Intérieur n'avait pourtant
pas de quoi la ramener dans son projet
de loi sur l'immigration a fait les
frais du conflit sur les retraites et va
être vendu à la découpe alors que le
premier flic de France traverse une
place délicate on le voit en difficulté
depuis quelques semaines sur la gestion
du maintien de l'ordre dans les
manifestations comment marche des
cortèges d'ailleurs il est ciblé par la
gauche après les images de guérilla à
sainte-solyn il sera auditionné mercredi
à l'Assemblée nationale en d'autres que
lui aurait fait le gros dos mais lui
choisit la contre-attaque en mode coup
de boule si j'ose dire parce qu'en
politique chevronnée Gérald Darmanin
sait qu'il y a rien de mieux pour faire
taire une disparus d'une polémique que
de lancer une nouvelle polémique et donc
dans le Journal du Dimanche là il a
sorti c'est un festivalence donc
pêle-mêle une cellule en tisane la
dissolution d'un collectif de défense
juridique des manifestants et puis
surtout le sans-prange son punching ball
favoris laupes et Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qu'il qualifie dont enfin dans les dont
il qualifie les discours de terrorisme
intellectuel d'extrême gauche alors quel
résultat pour
mettre des peaux de bananes dit-il en
orfèvre mais officieusement on le sait
c'est un secret de polichinelle au
gouvernement que Gérard d'avalin nourrit
de plus hautes ambitions et pourquoi pas
Matignon pour commencer d'ailleurs c'est
pas lui qui avait conseillé Elisabeth
borne dans les derniers moments dans
passés par un vote au Palais Bourbon sur
la réforme des retraites en fait je
rentre d'armanin il sait qu'il est un
géant dans une macronie de nains
politiques qui n'a fait émerger personne
ou presque depuis 5 ans il vient de la
droite vers laquelle penche le second
quinquennat du président alors il Clive
il fait parler de lui souvent trop fort
souvent aussi à ses dépens mais au moins
on en parle ce qui n'est pas donné à
tous c'est fini terminal c'est quoi la
stratégie du du ministre de l'intérieur
alors dans l'interview il dit je
souhaite rester ministre l'intérieur
jusqu'aux Jeux olympiques de Paris pour
pour appliquer tout ce qu'on a mis en
place faut-il le croire quoi
évidemment c'est quoi ça stratégie de
façon très très brillante c'est un
orfèvre c'est à dire que sa stratégie
mais pour l'instant je pense qu'il
avance au pas à pas c'est-à-dire que il
va voir un petit peu ce qui se profile
parce que le risque évidemment c'est de
se brûler les ailes aussi à Matignon si
jamais il devait viser les miser pour
après alors à ses proches il dit mais
non mais non mais jamais voilà après
évidemment qu'il était sans doute un des
plus brillants de sa génération c'est
quelqu'un qui qui a des vrais talents
politiques évidemment il y a un très bon
portrait de lui dans le monde
aujourd'hui qui qui voilà mais on a des
troupes derrière lui si je pense par
exemple si on pense à une bagarre entre
un Édouard Philippe ou un Gérald
Darmanin est-ce qu'il a des troubles
derrière lui il peut incarner selon moi
ce que ce qui faisait la force de
Nicolas Sarkozy dans son premier dans sa
première campagne c'est une France
populaire et il le dit il le répète mais
là aussi il colle à son sujet avec avec
une certaine intelligence parce que
personne ne peut lui nier ce fait et
c'est ce qui fait que Fabien Roussel a
une proximité avec lui alors évidemment
il n'a jamais il n'appartiendra à un
gouvernement et et je parle du leader
communiste jamais il n'acceptera de
participer à un gouvernement de de
Gérald Darmanin comme il y avait un
doute je les ai appelés ils me l'ont
confirmé mais enfin il y a eu un doute
déjà parce qu'en fait il y avait déjà eu
parce que Fabien Roussel avait déjà dit
pendant la campagne qui pouvait y avoir
non pas avec Elisabeth borne mais enfin
lui il serait pas opposé comme les
communistes c'est un peu leur tradition
de participer à un gouvernement d'union
nationale voilà parce que c'est cette
question qui se pose aussi en fonction
de ce que sera la France d'ici deux
trois ans et évidemment que les
questions internationales sont là aussi
pour nous dire que nos plans sont beaux
mais que la réalité pourrait se rappeler
à nous assez vite mais il n'a que
pensez-vous de cette c'est aussi dans
l'interview vous l'avez évoqué
rapidement à Mathieu de du ministre
d'intérieur cette cellule anti-zades
avec des juristes spécialisés
je vois vos yeux étonnés pour le moment
ça ne parle très peu mais cellules
anti-annonce on sait que dans son
maintien de l'ordre en tout cas il y a
vraiment quelque chose qui lorifie c'est
cette idée qu'on puisse installer du
désordre donc notamment dans sainte
Soline ce qui lui a été reproché c'est
de se dire mais pourquoi envoyer autant
de force de l'or et lui il faut vraiment
éviter l'installation la durée dans le
conflit donc on suppose que la cellule
en tisane sera donc en quelque sorte une
cellule j'imagine au sein du ministère
de l'intérieur et au sein de des forces
de l'ordre qui surveilleraient l'idée
qu'on en arrive pas à une occupation
illégale du territoire
préfet pour interdire les juriste aura
plutôt tendance à lui dire que de toute
façon pour la répression il faut arriver
après l'effet donc que que faire d'une
cellule a priori de contrôle de quelque
chose qui n'existe pas encore ça me pose
quand même beaucoup de questions mais
indépendamment de ça ce qui est malin on
l'a dit politiquement c'est de c'est de
montrer qu'il occupe le terrain de
montrer qu'il occupe le terrain aussi de
l'Intérieur et de la Sécurité parce que
il faut se rappeler que ça a été un des
grands thèmes quand même de la
présidentielle que ce sujet est un petit
peu tombé à l'eau et qu'on le voit
réapparaître à chaque manifestation
sociale on se parle du schéma de
maintien de l'ordre de la manière aussi
dans la France à d'incarner ces fortes
de l'ordre de la légitimité et la crise
de confiance quand elle est politique
elle devient très souvent aussi associée
au rôle de l'État à la place de l'État
et et je pense que c'est un sujet qui ne
faut pas abandonner donc peut-être qu'il
y a une forme de c'est c'est malin
politiquement de d'occuper ce terrain là
on va continuer de parler de la nuque
juste après notamment de cette
législasive partielle dans l'Ariège mais
peut-être un mot quand même Bastien
François sur bon voilà c'est vous nous
l'avez dit elle est destinée à provoquer
la polémique et peut-être à allumer à
contrefeu le terrorisme intellectuel de
l'extrême gauche quand vous lisez ça
dans la dans les propos du ministre de
l'Intérieur qu'est-ce que ça vous
inspire j'aurais tendance à dire tout ce
qui est excessif etc mais surtout je
suis pas certain que ça soit si malaxeur
quand Nicolas Sarkozy était ministre de
l'intérieur alors il faisait aussi il
était un vrai ministre de l'intérieur
mais il parlait d'autre chose
voilà il était pas que sur ce créneau là
en fait dans maintenant il occupe le
créneau et il s'enferme un peu dans ce
créneau
potentiel à la présidentielle assez
rapidement quand
les politiques étrangères et d'ailleurs
ça énervait beaucoup le président de la
République de l'époque parce que qui
d'ailleurs le remettait à sa place parce
que il était déjà président pratiquement
bon donc là Darmanin il est quand même
sur un petit créneau alors et finalement
ça fait beaucoup parler bon
ça renvoie à presque aucune réalité
parce que je suis pas un spécial mais
faire une ZAD en pleine campagne ça ça
n'arrivera jamais je veux dire parce que
vous en voyez deux bulldozers c'est
terminé pendant la nuit bon les ADD
quand même c'est des constructions il
faut il faut être dans la forêt il nous
a de là-bas sainte Soline ou des ADDES
comme ça ça c'est du fantasme de
ministre mais non voilà moi je trouve
que c'est pas nécessairement très malin
en plus à un moment il voudrait devenir
Premier ministre enfin je sais pas alors
effectivement il occupe très bien le
rôle il sature une sature l'espace
public
de de ses propos et des réactions à ses
propos
allez il nous reste 6 minutes pour
parler de la Nupe grâce à Steve Jourdain
qui va entrer sur ce plateau bonsoir
Steve bonsoir Thomas bienvenue à vous
donc c'est terrible cet élection dans la
riège qui provoque des troubles de les
mois même au niveau national la guerre
des gauches épisode je sais plus combien
vous êtes peut-être passé à côté mais
une élection législative partielle se
déroulait effectivement ce week-end en
arrière j'en département en creuses
depuis très longtemps en finale du
scrutin on retrouvait d'un côté
dissidente socialiste Martine Froget et
de l'autre Bénédicte taurine député
insoumise sortante candidate de la nupes
c'est la première qu'il a emporté hier
avec un score d'un peu plus de 60% des
voix écoutez je suis ravie ce soir parce
que pour moi la gauche républicaine a
gagné il y avait deux de gauche c'est
voilà aujourd'hui c'est la
social-démocratie qui qui gagne
bon une élection dont la première
circonscription de l'Ariège est-ce que
c'est vraiment déterminant pour l'avenir
de la France c'est peut-être un détail
pour vous pour la majorité des Français
et pour l'équilibre des forces à
l'Assemblée nationale mais pour les
socialistes ça veut dire beaucoup
Martine projet est une candidate sans
étiquette c'est-à-dire qu'elle n'avait
pas le maillot du Parti socialiste sur
elle au moment de se présenter devant
les électeurs et pourtant beaucoup chez
les socialistes tirent des enseignements
du scrutin écoutez la présidente de la
région
occitanique Carole Delga depuis un an on
veut se nous faire croire que si on
n'est pas d'accord ici on n'est pas
soumis à un seul homme on est contre
l'union de la gauche non de la gauche et
moi j'ai toujours prouvé Carole et pour
l'Union à gauche mais pas avec n'importe
qui c'est à dire pas avec les insoumis
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon les insoumis qui
évidemment tirent eux aussi des leçons
de ce scrutin oui on va écouter
manuellement c'était ce matin dans la
matinale
la candidate dissidente a été le
réceptacle de tous les battus du premier
tour de la candidate macroniste du
premier tour qui je le rappelle quand
même a fait 10% des voix c'est un
enseignement qui est très important d'un
point de vue national jusqu'au candidat
du Rassemblement national qui a été
éliminé au premier tour si Madame Delga
ou monsieur Cazeneuve considère que
c'est un enseignement pour la suite
d'être élu au deuxième tour face à
laupes avec le soutien de la droite et
de l'extrême droite je les laisse à ces
approximations où je les laisse assez
considérations dans quel groupe siège
Ratel sur les bancs socialistes de
l'Assemblée nationale ou sur ce du
groupe liotte le groupe liberté et
territoire qui accueille déjà des
dissidences socialistes elles de son
côté dit vouloir céger avec ses
camarades socialistes mais tout le monde
ne partage pas vraiment son enthousiasme
surtout Twitter hier Olivier fort le
patron du PS parle d'une victoire à la
Pyrrhus réalisée contre la gauche et
contre les écologistes on a connu
accueille plus chaleureux on sera demain
ce que décidera le groupe socialiste
merci beaucoup Steve Jourdain c'est
peut-être un détail pour vous et jouer
du piano debout évidemment on a tous
trouvé LA référence en a régulièrement
dans vos papiers Sophie dravidaldi quoi
cette législative partielle de l'état de
la nupaise je voudrais vraiment qu'on se
concentre je disais en titre
menacé d'implosion voilà c'est peut-être
que j'exagère un peu mais qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez alors en fait l'interview
de Fabien Roussel attention de pas la
de ne pas mal la comprendre parce que
quand il dit la nupaise bon en fait il
faut aller plus loin
la nuque elle est dépassée il faut
rassembler bien au-delà rassembler de
l'anneau de l'arme c'est-à-dire que la
nuit pèse pour lui c'était intense celui
des législatives mais il faut aller
au-delà c'est-à-dire qu'ils regardent le
Sénat encore une fois où il parle de
l'union de la gauche bon mais de fait ce
que ça montre c'est que il reste des
tensions très très fortes entre une
partie du PS et le reste de la news et
la question c'est de savoir ce que va
prendre comme place cette cette partie
du PS je dirais un tiers du PS qui a
quand même perdu aux élections puisque
Olivier fort l'a emporté et assez
facilement au dernier congrès et donc là
on voit bien Nicolas maillet Rossignol
le numéro 2 du PS parce qu'il a fallu
trouver un arrangement on voit bien
Carole Delga la présidente de la région
qui est d'ailleurs un tout petit peu
concurrencé par Bernard Cazeneuve qui
apprend monter son propre mouvement qui
s'appelle convention et puis le maire de
Montpellier Michael Delafosse tout ça
forme un espèce d'ensemble radicalement
opposé non pas à l'union de la gauche
mais aux insoumis et donc on va voir un
peu comment ça prend par la suite parce
que pour l'instant Jean-Luc Mélenchon a
pris du poil de la bête pendant cette
réforme des retraites il faut savoir
qu'il était quand même très très
concurrence enfin disons mise en
difficulté y compris au sein de son
propre mouvement et donc je dirais il
faut attendre un peu que tout ça repose
Mathieu c'est toujours difficile de
tirer des enseignements généraux d'un
instrumental mais est-ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que sur une terre de gauche
première circonscription de l'Ariège
elle est de gauche depuis le début de la
Troisième République après trois mois de
conflit sur les retraites où on a
beaucoup vu beaucoup entendu la nupes et
ben la nuit pèse ne parvient pas à
fédérer derrière elle une majorité des
lecteurs et c'est une autre candidate de
gauche avec un autre discours qui le
fait et ça les insoumis si je peux me
permettre parce que vraiment
toute l'excès de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
pendant cette campagne des retraites
mais Bénédicte torrent qui fait
moins de voix au second tour qu'elle en
a fait au premier tour de législatives
de juin dernier donc ça montre quand
même que cette ligne là mais en tout cas
pas majoritaire et c'est à dire sur une
terre de gauche comme l'Ariège un mot de
conclusion là dessus oui bah moi je
crois que ça en fait c'est un problème
pour le Parti socialiste et pas pour la
pas pour la louper parce que la nuit
pèse c'est quoi c'est un accord
électoral et depuis qu'est-ce que ça a
donné
pas un groupe plusieurs groupes ils
votent pas les mêmes lois
ils se sont quand même super engueulés
au sortir du débat sur les retraites
tous les autres parties de la nups
reprochant à les filles et son attitude
ils iront pas ensemble au prochaines
élections européennes donc franchement
je pense que c'est
l'assemblée
ils apprennent à travailler ensemble je
suis pas en train de dire que c'est mort
je dis simplement ça c'est vraiment un
micro épisode qui va affecter surtout
les équilibres internes aux parties
socialistes et l'avenir d'union de la
gauche et à mon avis sera encore semé
beaucoup d'obstacles mais
pourquoi pas merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce à ce